[Musique]
ramel ça veut dire que vous voulez
signer ram l etat et les c'est son
stagiaire bernard angoisse comme des
malades depuis trois ans ouais je fais
un show case owen et raptor c'est mignon
t'inquiète cette fois ça va être la
bonne
ton destin est en jeu le plus important
c'est impressionné tout le monde sait ce
qu'il fait alors assure merci c'est
sympa je sais que c'est vraiment pas une
surprise mais wiz khalifa fume de
l'herbe qui défonce tout
bien oui stars en herbe les violentes
chutes et rebonds cible
on
il fait une crise d'épilepsie faut
filmer ça ils monde l'appelle
l'épileptique par contre je trouve que
la danse est plutôt drôle tel rappeur
épileptiques
non non non aux tomates mouassa qui
limite
est-ce que ça car je joue ouais c'est
clair et me internet peut lancer ou
détruire une carrière j'ai fait la
promesse que si tu n'essaies être ton
manager je me donnerai à fond ce soir
c'est le meilleur acteur que vous verrez
de votre ville y aura plein de gens
super cool french montana tegris you say
push à dire tu pourras lui crache et lrx
dans la tronche et tu pourras signer sur
son label tantôt va comme ça tu es que
la situation est tendue je mords ça a
vraiment est toujours besoin d aide mais
elle n'a pas tort tu as besoin de dette
pour la majorité des trucs si vous
voulez que je vous laisse entre est
revenu avec un tat [ __ ] revenais pas
sinon vous voudriez venir à l'after de
french montana non i'm here and ont
décroché un contrat avant le lever du
jour
tu allais entêtant toi mais je vous
kiffe grave des caches de la jetée gages
[Musique]